welcome to the 42nd annual Dr Martin
Luther King Jr celebration we are
excited about today's event and they're
happy that you're here today to
celebrate with us
I would like to take this moment to
thank president Rafael Rife and
Christine Rife who are our host for this
morning I would also like to thank our
honored guest and keynote speaker
Freeman habowski III president of the
University of Maryland Baltimore County
thank you for joining us
last night at a special dinner the MLK
Junior leadership Award winners were
announced we are very pleased to
recognize these individuals and groups
who embody the ideals of Dr King in
service to the community
today I would like to share with the
audience this year's award winners the
names of this year's winners and all the
names I'm about to announce are in your
program if you want to follow along
please stand up as I call your name
please hold your applause till the end
Rashi August
George ciao
Barbara Johnson
Ethan Zuckerman
fossil free MIT
black graduate student Association
now I would like to recognize the
2015-2016 MLK visiting professors and
Scholars please stand as I call your
name and again please hold your applause
until the end
vertunde Kula
LaShonda Corley
Israel and Cube
Kenneth Reeves
Jacqueline Taylor
I would like to thank all the members of
the Martin Luther King Jr celebration
subcommittee of the presidential
committee on race and diversity to whom
we own this wonderful event please stand
as I call your names committee members
include Raul bulky
Shannon Clark
Sharon Clark
Philip clay
Sally hashlinger
ebony earn
Alice Johnson
William kendrum
Deborah liverman
Paul peruvano
Xena Queen
Christine Rife
Marina Robinson
Toby weiner
Reverend John wesnack
thank you all for contributing to the
success of this event
the theme for this year's celebration is
truth and power students leading for
change
we're here this morning to celebrate
Life and Legacy of Dr King but also to
reflect on the question what can and
should be done in the face of systematic
Injustice
individual actions can make a difference
but do they add up to something more
how can we work together for broader and
deeper social changes
Dr King was able to mobilize a
generation to challenge rhesus laws and
practices through Civil Disobedience and
collect collective action it is our turn
now what is the next step